Speaker 1: As I'm sure most of you would guess, I
don't typically wait around for the next episode
of Tucker Carlson's Fox News propaganda program,
but I actually was curious as to what the program
would look like last night. Over the weekend,
as we covered yesterday, there was a horrifying
terrorist mass shooting targeting black people in
Buffalo, New York, in which in total ten people
were killed and 13 injured. The 18 year old white
domestic born shooter inspired by the ideas of
the great replacement and white birthrates that
have been just everywhere on right wing media
over the last few years. The shooter went to
Buffalo looking to kill black people and indeed
he killed many black people. And I was waiting
to see how his Tucker Carlson going to spin it.
How is Ben SHAPIRO going to spin it? How is Fox
News going to spin? And well, we immediately saw,
as we looked at yesterday, Fox News talking
about video game violence and continuing to
fearmonger about terrorist immigrants
coming over the US-Mexico border. So
we saw the General Fox News approach, but the
shooter's manifesto had almost verbatim language
that we saw on the Tucker Carlson program. So
the question was, what's Tucker going to say?
And we're going to look at clips. And it was
truly a surreal episode in absolutely every
way. How was Tucker going to do it? How is Tucker
going to separate himself? How was he going to
minimize while part of it bizarrely included,
talking about Rwanda? If you can believe it,
I'm talking about the African country of Rwanda, a
completely I can't think of a better term for it.
Kafkaesque episode of the Tucker Carlson Program.
So let's start with the first clip in which Tucker
tries to distance himself, as well as Fox News
from the Buffalo shooter, who was, of course,
inspired by the conspiracy theories that Tucker
and others have been pushing. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: But what he wrote does not add up
to a manifesto. It's not a blueprint for a
new extremist political movement, much less the
potential inspiration for a racist revolution.
Anyone who claims that it is is lying or hell.
Speaker 1: If you read it, you realize that
that's exactly what it is. It's taking the
conspiracy theories that Tucker and others
have been repeating on their programs and saying,
Well, the solution is we've got to go and kill
people who aren't white. And that's what he did.
Speaker 2: Didn't read it. Instead, again, Ron's
letter is a rambling pastiche
of slogans and Internet meme,
some of which flatly contradict one another. The
document is not recognizably left wing or right
wing. It's not really political at all.
Speaker 1: That's obviously completely
untrue because it aligns with the exact
political ideology espoused by those
surrounding Donald Trump and on this so-called
populist right, where they sound all about the
middle class. But then the solutions are, well,
we've got to do something about these nonwhite
immigrants coming into the country.
Speaker 2: The document is crazy. It's
the product of a disease, an organized mind.
Speaker 1: And remember, to some degree, we can
say there's something mentally not working with
these folks. But as I mentioned before yesterday,
the manifesto is quite cogent and coherent
as far as these manifestos go. And writing
this off as simply mental illness doesn't
make any sense. And remember, most mentally
ill people never commit any violence.
Speaker 2: At one point, Gardner suggests
that Fox News is part of some global conspiracy
against him. He writes, Like the mental patient,
he is disjointed, irrational, paranoid. Now
that's true. Not that it makes the atrocities
he committed easier to bear. If your daughter was
murdered on Saturday in Buffalo, you wouldn't care
why the killer did it or who he voted for. But
the truth about Patton Gendron does tell you
a lot about the ruthlessness and
dishonesty of our political leadership.
Within minutes of Saturday's shooting before all
of the bodies of those ten murdered Americans
have even been identified by their loved ones,
professional Democrats had begun a coordinated
campaign to blame those murders on their political
opponents. They did it, they said, immediately.
Patron Gendron was the heir to Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Okay, so listen, I am sympathetic to
the fraught nature of immediately making political
declarations. That's why often with these cases,
I won't cover it the next day. In this case, it
happened on a weekend, so we had time. To the
extent that anybody before we had information
made any claims that weren't yet based, in fact
that's wrong. And I would denounce that. I didn't
actually see that. But I also didn't pay attention
to the news on the day of. I read about everything
after the fact. But the manifesto can be seen
only as an almost verbatim reproduction of the
things we've heard from Tucker and from other
right wing media. Now, as I mentioned earlier, at
one point, Tucker talked about Rwanda. He. Put up
a quote from 2004 New York Times about Rwanda and
the Rwandan genocide. Just completely bizarre,
bizarre stuff. And then another and another
moment, Tucker, again focused on that. This
was just a lone mentally ill guy. That's it.
Speaker 2: Because a mentally ill teenager
murdered strangers. You cannot be allowed to
express your political views out loud. That's
what they're telling you. That's what they've
wanted to tell you for a long time. But Saturday's
massacre gives them a pretext, a justification.
Speaker 1: So playing on the idea that all of a
sudden now, because of one mentally ill guy,
completely disconnected from any political
rhetoric, I mean, other than the fact that the
manifesto contains verbatim rhetoric from my
show made me being speaking as Tucker here. What
really this is about is about silencing your
political views. Imagine being so depraved or
dishonest or ignorant. I don't know which it is
with Tucker to pretend that what this is really
about is simply silencing the political speech
of people like Tucker who just want to give their
opinions. Now, again, this thing of mentally ill,
when you look at the manifesto, it's articulate,
fascist, racist, anti-Semitic hate linked to ideas
that we've seen propagated by Tucker and others,
which we will look at again later in the show.
Something is obviously wrong with people
who commit these acts of violence.
But the mental illness, the merely mental illness
line used to excuse the political reality of these
people's motivations is immoral and or
dishonest and may be just ignorant. But
I have a hard time believing that with Tucker,
it's ignorance. So a bizarre Tucker Carlson show,
almost as bizarre as what Ben SHAPIRO had
to say, which we're going to go to next.